in this lesson we're going to talk about
our Clank so this is an important
concept understand for the new revised
s80 so some formulas you want to
familiarize yourself with or memorize
would be these ones here circumference
equals 2pi r circumference is also equal
to pi times diameter since twice three
is the diameter but the key formula here
is the arc length formula which is you
take the circumference right which is 2
PI R or pi times diameter and you
multiply it by the fraction of the whole
circle so for example if I had a circle
like this just a real simple example say
that central angle is 90 degrees see
what you would be doing is you be taking
90 / 360 which is really one fourth so
you're really taking one fourth of the
whole circumference 2 PI R so you're
taking the central angle / 360 that
gives you the fraction of the whole
circumference okay so let's look at some
examples see if you can pause the video
and do these on your own and we'll go
through them together so example one
says what is the length of minor arc a B
this arc right here so my attorneys it's
a you know going to be less than 180
it's smaller you don't to go all the way
around like that so it's the shorter
distance okay so what do you think for
that one pause the video see if you can
do it on your own what i would do is use
the formula over here we've got 30 / 360
so that's 1 12 so we're looking at 112
of the whole circumference times with
circumference which is the 2 PI R so
we've got 112 times 8 pi which is going
to give us 8 PI over 12 inches or you
can reduce those four goes into both of
these so you can say 2 PI over 3 inches
you can also put 3.14 for pi if it wants
a decimal answer you know you've got a
couple options here ok so then for
example 2 it says if minor arc QD that's
the shorter arc right here has a length
of 14 pi inches what is the diameter
okay of the circle so go ahead and pause
the video so you can do this one on your
own and we'll go through it together so
I'm going to use this formula again here
the arc length formula 120 / 360 so
we're really looking at one-third of the
whole circumference
so x 2 PI R equals the length of the arc
which it tell us us 14 pi inches okay so
let's see if we can solve this soaking
by both sides by piles cancel each other
out this is actually one third times two
okay so that's actually two thirds r
equals 14 and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to multiply by the reciprocal
three have okay to get the r by itself
so that comes out to 21 because that's
42 divided by two is twenty-one but
that's the radius they want the diameter
so the diameter remember is a double the
radius right so it's the distance from
here to here it's actually two are so if
the radius is 21 the diameter is going
to be 42 inches so again you want to
memorize these formulas theta / 360
times two PI R to get the arc length and
then you also just want to kind of
familiarize yourselves with these
formulas although I these they give you
at the beginning of the test but this
one you want to know so again arc length
something important to know for the s80
I'll see you in the next lesson